one of the most notable differences
right now between the democratic and
republican parties outside of ideology
is that the republican party
not only isn't ashamed to nominate and
elect people who just can't think whose
brains really don't work
they almost seem proud of it in some
strange way and one such person is
radical republican congresswoman from
georgia marjorie taylor green fresh off
the
primary win that she had last week who
now has gaffed again using the term
peach tree dish
rather than petri dish now we'll get to
that and when i say she's gaffed again
i'll remind you at one point trying to
talk about some kind of
coved gestapo
using the term gazpacho which is of
course a cold spanish tomato soup
sometimes with a cucumber in it which i
think is a nice thing to add to gazpacho
okay take a listen to this not only do
we have the dc jail which is the dc
gulag but now we have nancy pelosi's
gazpacho police spying on members of
congress now some people speculated she
does this on purpose to get attention
no she doesn't there is absolutely no
evidence whatsoever that she has any
idea about the word gazpacho versus
gestapo it there is absolutely no reason
to think that well she's done it again
and this time she's talking about uh
fake meats and she seems to think that
fake meat is grown not in a petri dish
which is of course you know a little uh
plastic
uh
container
for holding cells bacteria whatever um
that it is a peach tree dish it's a dish
in which you put a tree that grows
peaches you have to accept the fact that
the government totally wants to provide
surveillance on every part of your life
they want to know when you're eating
they want to know if you're eating a
cheeseburger which is very bad because
bill gates wants you to eat his fake
meat that grows in a peachtree dish a
peachtree dish you'll probably get a
little zap inside your body and that say
no no don't eat a real cheeseburger you
need to eat the fake the fake burger the
fake meat from bill gates
okay
so it's just a gaff right i mean who
cares well it's actually much bigger
than just any individual gaff
these people can barely put together a
coherent thought and it doesn't matter
we have a political party we have a
members of a political party in this
country
that don't care about the fact that
their candidates can't think they can't
think and they still vote for them in
normal countries these folks would not
stand a chance at being in positions of
power and they'll come back and say oh
how elitist david
you think only people who use real words
and can speak and think a little bit
should be able to be in well
i'm not saying it should be illegal for
them to run what i'm saying is that a
sane country would never vote for these
people
look at what's going on with herschel
walker in the senate i we played these
clips last week but i'll include them
here because they're relevant
herschel walker is endorsed by trump
former football player won his senate
primary in georgia essentially unopposed
he can't speak he can't think
okay here he was asked by cnn reporter
manu raju whether there should be any
new gun laws and his answer was what i
like to do is see it in everything and
stuff
that that's the whole answer
hey roger with cnn
are you do you support any new gun laws
in the wake of this texas shooting
do you support the new gun laws in the
wake up
he likes to see it and everything and
stuff then up the next day he appeared
on fox news and he said he would solve
school shootings with a department
that can look at young men
looking at young women
looking at social media that's the
solution see that it's a person willing
that weapon you know cain kia able you
know and uh you know that's the problem
that we have and i said what we need to
do is look into how we can stop those
things you know he talked about doing a
disinformation what about getting a
department that can look at young men
that's looking at women that are looking
at just social media what about doing
that looking into things like okay so
that's his idea we want to get a
department that can look at young men
looking at women looking at social media
they cannot speak
they cannot think and it doesn't
dissuade republicans it doesn't dissuade
republicans and so the question becomes
how can you defeat a movement
whose
elected officials don't even have to
have a functioning brain
and that doesn't even dissuade the
voters it doesn't seem like reality
matters anymore and so how do you defeat
that i guess voter turnout on our side
but uh i mean listen that you we say
that every year and then there's always
like so-so voter turnout particularly in
midterms so i don't know i don't know
what to tell you one of our sponsors is
curiosity stream the only subscription
streaming service that specializes in
documentaries my audience can get a
curiosity stream subscription for only
about a dollar a month at
curiositystream.com
pacman we all know netflix then hulu
they have some documentaries but
curiosity stream has a way better
selection in every category i'm always
finding documentaries on curiosity
stream i can't find anywhere else i just
watched electing lincoln which is a
three-part series about what led to the
election of abraham lincoln fascinating
absolutely fascinating curiosity stream
has an app for all of your devices i've
always got it going on the tv or i can
do put it on my tablet when i travel
with curiosity stream i can explore a
new topic i never knew i'd be interested
in or
zone out with the great nature
documentary whatever you're looking for
it's there and you can get curiosity
stream for just 14.99 a year that's less
than two bucks a month when you go to
curiositystream.com pacman and use the
code pacman the link is down below